I'll give it that was an unpleasant
place I mean honestly you know you know
I'm reminded of if you don't want to
prevent the light of consciousness from
going extinct I'm all for that
I mean I'm not the kind of existential
risk type who says that you know it's
absolutely pivotal that we should
maintain the species or cost him one way
or another
III can't tend to be the kind of person
who thinks that almost everybody dying
is almost as bad as everybody dying but
nevertheless I'm all for not everybody
dying and so absolutely it would be nice
to have off planet civilizations but I
wouldn't try Mars I would build a much
more controlling but yeah yeah that kind
of thing yeah perhaps further away than
millions in order to preserve the
species you I need a fear alright and so
oh so you'd want to throw up a hundred
thousand in there and then just in case
[ __ ] up enough to world living space
right you know one that one is that musk
is finding a number of people literally
happy to go to Mars and never come back
right